The solution for
this is that in cycle 13,
we have already issued all the
instructions so no issue will happen.
We have already begun execution
of all these instructions,
so the correct answer obviously, will
not be that something else executes in
13 because we have
already begun execution.
We have already seen that
this begin executing in 13.
But, that's not the question.
The writing of the results, neither of
this can write the result in 13, and
all the other results have
already been written.
For commit however,
this result has been written in 12.
This is the very first instruction
that we are going to try to commit, so
this instruction will
actually commit in cycle 13.
So the correct answer is C for
commit, one because this is
the instruction that commits.
So this is also what
happens in cycle 13.